let me just ask in terms of your worries
of if we look 100 years from now we're
in the middle of
what is now a natural pandemic that from
the looks of it
it fortunately is not as bad as it could
have possibly been
if you look at the spanish flu if you
look at the history of pandemics
if you look at all the possible
pandemics that could have been that that
folks like bill gates are exceptionally
terrified about we've
i know many people are suffering uh but
it's
it's it's better than it could have been
uh so and
now we're talking about nuclear weapons
in terms of existential threats to us
as sinful humans uh what worries you the
most
is it nuclear weapons is is it
natural pandemics engineered pandemics
nanotechnology in my field of artificial
intelligence some people
are afraid of uh killer robots and
robots yeah
is there do you think in those
existential terms uh
and and do any aspect do any of those
things worry you
i am certainly not confident that
my children and grandchildren will
experience the benefits of civilization
that i have enjoyed i think it's
possible for our civilizations to break
down
catastrophically um i also
think that it's possible for our
civilizations to break down
progressively and i think they will
if we continue to have the explosion of
population
on the planet that we currently have i
mean
it's it's quite it's quite wrong to
think of our problems as mostly being
co2 if we can just solve co2
then we can go on having this you know
continually expanding economy everywhere
in the world of course you can't do that
okay i mean there is a finite you know
bearing capacity of our planet on the
resources of our planet on the resources
of our planet and
and we can't continue to do that so i
think there are lots of technical
reasons
why um a continually expanding
economy and and uh and civilization
is impossible and therefore um
actually i'm as much nervous about the
fact that our
population is eight billion or something
uh right now
worldwide as i am about um the fact that
you know a few million people would be
would be killed by
covid 19. i mean i don't want to be
callous about this but from the big
picture it seems like
that's much more of a problem
overpopulation
people not dying is ultimately more of a
problem
uh than people dying um so you know that
probably sounds incredibly callous to
your
listeners but i think it's simply you
know a sober assessment of the situation
is there is there
ways from the way those 8 billion or 7
billion or whatever the number is
live that could make it sustainable
uh you know because you've kind of
implied there's a kind of uh
we have especially in the west this kind
of capitalist view of uh
really consuming a lot of resources is
there a way to
like if you could change uh one thing or
a few things what would you
change to make this life make it look
more likely that your grandchildren have
a better life than you well okay so
let's talk a bit about energy because
that's something i know a lot a lot
about having thought about it most of my
career
in order to reach a steady-state co2
level
okay that's acceptable in terms of
global climate change and so on and so
forth
we need to reduce our
carbon emissions by at least a factor of
10 worldwide
okay what's more
you know the average
energy consumption and hence co2
emission of people in the world is
less than a tenth of what we
per capita of than what we have
in the west in america and europe and so
forth
so if you have in mind some utopia in
the future where we can
where we've reached a sustainable use of
energy
and we've also reached a situation in
which
there's far less inequity in the world
in the sense that people have share the
energy resources
more uniformly then what what that
is equivalent to would be to reduce the
co2
emissions in western economies
not by a factor of 10 but by a factor of
100 in other words has to go down to one
percent of what it is now
okay yeah so you know when people talk
about
uh you know let's use natural gas
because you know maybe it
only uses 60 of the energy of coal
it's complete nonsense we're that's not
not even scratching the surface of what
we
would need to do so
you know is that going to be feasible i
i
i very much doubt it and therefore i
actually doubt
that we can reach um a level of
energy um of
fossil energy use that is one percent
of the current use in the west without
totally dramatic changes either in
you know our society our use of of
energy and so forth which actually
of course is much of that energy is used
for producing food and so on and so
forth so it's actually
not so obvious that we can we can get we
can cut down our energy usage by that
factor
or we've got to reduce the human
population population
so you run up against that number that's
increasing still
and you don't think that could be it's
depressing no it's not uh
it's not it's not it's not depressing
it's um
it's difficult like many truths are uh
do you do you have a hope uh that there
could be a technological solution
in short no there is no technological
solution
to for example for population control i
mean we have the technology
just you know to prevent ourselves
bearing children that's not a problem
technology's in okay solved
the challenge is society the challenges
human choices the challenges almost
entirely
human and sociological not technology
not technology and when people thought
talk about energy they
they think that there's some kind of
technological magic bullet for this but
there isn't
okay and and there isn't for the reasons
i just mentioned
not because it's obvious there isn't but
actually there isn't uh
and and in in any case um
that it's true of energy it's true of
pollution it's true of human population
it's true of most of the big challenges
in our society are not scientific or
technological challenges
they're human sociological challenges
and that's why i think it's a terrible
mistake
even for folks like me who work at you
know well the high temple of science and
technology
in in america and maybe in the galaxy
yeah i mean
you know it's it's it's mit it's mit
best university in the world
it's it's a terrible mistake if we give
the impression
that technology is going to solve it all
technology will make
tremendous contributions and i think
it's it's worth working on it
but it's a disaster if you think it's
going to solve all of our problems and
and actually um you know i've written a
whole book about
the question of of scientism and the
and the over emphasis on science both as
a way of
of solving problems through technology
but also as a way of gaining knowledge i
think it's not all the knowledge there
is either
you